hello everyone and welcome to a really
spectacular game from the Spanish league
honor division between gookish and
gawaine Jones uh I've received many many
suggestions to show this game but I was
like okay I know that gookish is like
really dominating and he's winning
pretty much every game so naturally you
guys are uh suggesting games that he
played but then I saw the game and I was
like yeah okay I I realized why you guys
were suggesting it so we are going to
discuss many things in this video uh
like just how many Indians are there in
the in the world's top 20 classical
players and many other cool things but
first we need to check out this game uh
so it's gookash versus green Jones
bookish has the white pieces and he
opens with D4 and the ratings below
their names are their classical ratings
uh as they currently are not the live
ratings as you guys always um say uh
that that I've uh like these guys rated
this much and then uh well you know what
I'm talking about uh but yeah okay plays
the 4 we have Knight to F6 C for G6 by
Jones Knight the C3 and the D5 we have
the grunfeld defense on board and the
most popular way of dealing with this is
just C captures and D5 but gokish goes
for Knight to F3 yeah he goes for the
three Knights variation and of course I
know you are wondering if Knight the C6
is the Four Knights variation of the
groomfield and in fact it is not as it's
not a good move so don't play this so
Bishop to G7 by Jones and now Ponte E3
we have castles and sea captain D5
Knight captures and now Bishop the C4
uh putting pressure on the night tonight
the B6 can be played you can challenge
the bishop but also just Knight captures
on C3 uh going in a in a more classical
setup of B captures in C3 and pawn to C5
much like you would in a regular
groomfield setup trying to put pressure
on the center and uh take advantage of
The Rook still being on A1 so here
castles we have Queen to C7 and queen to
E2 now of course if C capture Sandy for
the bishop and C4 will be defended so
this is all a very very known stuff and
has been played before Knight to C6 with
Bishop to A3 and now Pawn to B6 nicely
defending the pawn here uh or rather you
could for example capture it but then
you just mess up your whole Pawn
structure I mean you don't really gain
anything this bishop just becomes too
big of a monster Rook 8 to C1 aligning
The Rook nicely with the queen and now
Bishop to B7 and here there are some
games where Rook after D1 was played
also uh Bishop the A6 is a normal trying
to trade off this monster Bishop but
here we we have Rook after sorry here we
have E4 by gookish and it is now as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game so let's see uh how the game
continues we have Knights day five
challenging the bishop here and just the
bishop back to D3 uh we have Bishop to
H6 a very interesting decision by uh by
Gawain uh moving the bishop away from
this diagonal but it does make sense you
you don't want white for example
to double up Rooks on the C file or even
just having a rook on the C file can be
annoying with the queen on C7 so look
back to B1 by gookish and now Rook 8 to
C8 we have Pawn to D5 and now E6
challenging this uh Central Pawn
structure we have Pawn to C4 and now
Rook C back to E8 aligning The Rook with
with the queen here so Queen back to C2
and now Pawn to F5 and um
uh although this is a very nice Pawn
break you can see that uh going really
Advanced those Pawns in front of his
King so it could be a bit dangerous with
Rook after E1 and now F captures an E4
Bishop captures and E Capture Sun D5 we
have C captures on D5 so he managed to
trade off um strong Center but wilkesh
at the end of this line is left with a
very strong pass to D Pawn he has the
bishop pair which could be very very
important with the King wide open here
imagine the Bishops on on these
diagonals you do not want to see that
and well it's just very interesting how
how Gawain can even continue playing
this here it seems that the only good
move is Queen to D6 like you have to
block this pawn and just hope for the
best that's basically your game plan
however he played Bishop the C8 he the
bishop isn't very useful here so he
wants to shift it over to F5 but now
gokish plays a truly truly remarkable
move uh and he plays Ponte D6 he gives
up the pawn his prized past the pawn in
order to open up lines towards the black
king and this is just um well truly like
something other out of the Paul morphe
era here we have Queen characters on D6
not Catherine also doesn't help so Queen
captures and D6 now Rook B to D1 now the
Rooks are controlling the D and D file
and it's very hard to find the square
for this queen like of course if you go
to here then Bishop B2 you you just uh
you you just uh help out the white in in
setting up pieces for the uh for the
attack so Queen to C7 and now Bishop to
D5 with the check and now King the h8
and of course Bishop to B2 with checks
so what can you play here of course the
bishop to G7 the bishop now has the
return and Perry the the attack of the
uh of White's dark Square bishop and now
Knight the G5 I'm putting more pressure
on this F7 square and here we have
Bishop to F5 yeah trading Rooks doesn't
help just captures captures and black is
still left with with the same dilemma of
what they actually do here so Bishop to
F5 attacking the queen but now uh
gookish plays a truly spectacular move
he plays Queen to C3 and he offers his
Queen uh which of course cannot be taken
I will show why because it's it's just
beautiful if Bishop captures in C3
Bishop captures with check now the black
king really has no squares you have to
block with the queen
uh and now Knight to F7 with check the
queen cannot capture uh the only thing
you can do is capture with the Rook but
then it's just a nice mating too as the
queen of course is pin so yeah that's
that's it and if you don't capture you
can play King to G8 but now it also
doesn't help you or just um getting
destroyed here 96 check the King has to
move again or you can block Bishop T6 it
doesn't really matter everything loses
the bishop captures King captures Knight
captures Rook with check Rook captures
an eighth Rook captures and E6 Rook
captures sorry about that Rook captures
an E6 Bishop captures and at the end of
this very nice line uh White is upper
full Rook so of course after Queen to C3
Bishop characters and C3 is impossible
so here we have Rook capture Sunny one
with check Rook captures anyone and
fonte H6 uh but now uh uh Lucas actually
has a beautiful beautiful forced
Checkmate but I'm not just gonna show it
to you feel free to pause the video and
try to find the absolute best move for
gookish while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
spectacular idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Queen captures on G7 uh I dropped
the queen there sorry about that but I
was too excited to make this move we can
of course do it in slow motion there you
have it Queen captures and G7 uh really
really a wonderful idea and now it
whatever whatever uh going does it's
just a forced Checkmate in eight moves
if we include the queen move that's
basically a force Checkmate in nine so
Queen captures Here and Now Rook the E7
and it was in this position on move 30
that Gawain Jones resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
what what an attack I will show you the
rest of the game uh simply because it's
uh it's a forced line but before we do
that I feel that it is more than
necessary to award good cash none other
than the the legendary morphy head there
you have it Gucci you have deserved it
for playing such as in such a
spectacular way giving up the D6 pawn
and then everything just you know fell
into the right place here you have no
moves the queen can't move uh you can
you you can't really do anything if you
capture the Knight just Bishop captures
on G7 and now you're just going on a
nice King hunt King H7 Bishop captures
and fade opens up a discovery you have
to move the king another check now again
you move the king Bishop F6 check you
force the king down the board King H6
now rookie threatening Checkmate here so
King H5 and now Bishop F3 check whatever
you do let's say G4 doesn't really
matter Rook to h8 will be Checkmate so
however black plays this he will get
checkmated in um well nine moves the
most after the queen is sacrificed in
this most most uh spectacular way not
sacrifice but um given for the attack
but this I mean seeing all of this um uh
starting with uh just going not playing
Queen to D6 is absolutely incredible
after this just look at this D6 giving
up a pawn taking control of the of the
open file with rotate the D1 Queen C7
Bishop D5 check King has to move now
Bishop B2 check Bishop has to block
Knight G5 without a move leaving back
basically without a move Bishop F5 and
now Queen to C3 now getting out of the
attack and offering a full Queen which
cannot be accepted now Rook captures
Rook captures and now Pawn to H6 and of
course now comes Queen captures and G7
Queen captures and The Rook E7 and here
going resigned truly truly spectacular
and I know you guys are interested what
does this mean for our standings in the
in the world's top 20. and these are the
standings so you can see uh Magnus still
in first place of course with 2856 see
it doesn't seem like he will be losing
that anytime soon but he is a minus 4.7
uh after that lost the Hans Neiman uh so
then we have ding uh also another member
of the 2800 Club in um second place and
then the the usual gang with Anand in
nine still hanging in there in the top
10 but you have Arjun erigasi number 18
and good cash uh in number 20. he's
currently on 27 30 and as he is playing
more games in this league if he wins one
more game he is very likely to overtake
both Duda and Eric AC but then again
like uh when we talk about Derek AC it
will take a few more uh victories to to
catch up the the to the likes of grishu
Dominguez MBL mamidabra job of is that's
another 15 points and that's basically a
whole different power level
uh so yeah that's the game and the the
uh world top 20 uh standings hope you
guys enjoyed the really uh spectacular
game thank you for suggesting it as with
so many things happening in the world I
might have missed it as I'm not um you
know vividly following the Spanish
league honor division so again really
thank you for such a suggestion and once
again big big congratulations to gookish
on achieving um uh such a masterpiece I
mean this is uh this is a game you want
to put in every book uh with tactics you
know where you just want to show it to
beginners uh and uh you know once they
see it they will love chess for the rest
of their lives that's the the kind of
game this is uh so yeah and once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Dustin Lackey uh vasudevan
sir nivasan and martial
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the trust world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day